hello and welcome to maths implied in
this video we are going to talk about
the type 1 hypersensitivity reaction our
immune system consists mainly of two
types of immunity the cellular immunity
which consists of the different types of
cells and the humoral immunity which
consists of the antibodies and the cells
producing them whenever a harmful
organism enters our body our immune
system is able to sense it and destroys
it by different mechanism this is known
as the sensitivity of our immune system
although it normally defends us against
infections our immune system can get
excessively sensitive against non
harmful things like dust pollen
medicines and many food substances this
excessive activity of our immune system
leads to local and systemic symptoms
that can range from harmless itching to
severe conditions like hypotensive shock
and laryngospasm this excessive activity
of our immune system to seemingly
non-harmful antigens is known as
hypersensitivity
now hypersensitivity reactions are of
four types dye one to type for which
differ from each other as different
components of immune system are involved
in each for in this video we will only
talk about the type 1 hypersensitivity
reaction
allergies are a classic example of type
1 hypersensitivity reaction which can be
allergies to foods like peanuts eggs
fish or allergies to dust and pollen
bronchial asthma is also an example of
type 1 hypersensitivity reaction now
let's look at the pathological mechanism
involved in type 1 reaction and to
understand this we are going to take the
example of how a person develops dust or
pollen allergy the first phase of type 1
reaction involves sensitization this
sensitization is to the antigen which
refers to dust or pollen in this case
this is the phase when the person has
not yet developed hyper sensitivity to
the allergen when the person is exposed
to the dust or pollen it enters the body
through two main routes the respiratory
membrane of lungs and the skin at both
these places we have specialized cells
known as the antigen presenting cells in
the lungs we have the pulmonary antigen
presenting cells and in the skin we have
the Langerhans cells these cells capture
the minut antigens that are present on
the dust or pollen and they take these
antigens to the T cells
to be exact the naive cd4 T cells the
naive cd4 T cells when exposed to these
antigens become mature and are now known
as mature cd4 T cells these T cells
produce a lot of chemicals like
interleukin 4 interleukin 5 interleukin
13 and many more but in the
sensitization phase the most important
cytokine is interleukin 4 which acts on
P lymphocytes now as most of you may
already know the antibodies are produced
by b-cells and the type of antibodies
are b-cell produces is known as the
class of antibodies whether it be IgA
IgG or IGM this interleukin 4 acts on B
cells and leads to a phenomenon known as
class switching which essentially means
that the interleukin 4 makes a B cells
to switch the class of antibodies that
they are producing to immunoglobulin E
so the B cells which are now exposed to
enter looking for only produce IgE now
why is this important because the main
type of antibody that is involved in
type 1 reaction is the IgE only let's
look at how this IgE antibody that is
produced can identify the allergen that
led to the initial sensitization this
antibody gets attached to mast cells and
basophils which are the two most
important cells involved in type 1
reaction
the mast cells and basophils have a
special type of receptor on their
surface this is known as the FC epsilon
R one receptor now if you have a little
bit of background knowledge about the
structure of antibodies you know that
the antibodies have our FC part with
which they bind to the cells and the F a
B part with which they bind the antigens
the FC epsilon R one receptor on mast
cells and basophils they have a very
high affinity for the FC portion of IgE
antibodies that are produced as a result
of class switching of b-cells these
antibodies go and attach to these
receptors on mast cells and basophils
with this the phase of sensitization is
complete and we get these mast cells and
basophils which have been armed with
these antibodies the IgE antibodies
these are waiting for the same allergen
to enter the body and start the phase of
reaction which is the second phase of
type one reaction the reaction phase
begins when the same allergen enters the
body again the IgE antibodies recognize
these allergens and since these
antibodies are attached to mast cells
and basophils these signal the cells to
release lots of chemicals that are
present inside them these chemicals are
known as the mediators of inflammation
and are responsible for symptoms of
immediate hypersensitivity like itching
hypotension bronchospasm and shock the
reaction phase is further subdivided
into two main phases the immediate
reaction phase that develops in minutes
after the repeated exposure to allergen
and a late reaction phase that develops
minutes to hours after the exposure to
the allergen and the basic difference
between the immediate reaction and the
late reaction is that in the immediate
reaction phase the chemicals that are
already formed and stored inside the
mast cells are released whereas in the
late phase new chemicals are synthesized
which maintain the hypersensitivity
reaction for ours the immediate reaction
starts in minutes after the exposure to
the allergen as soon as the
reenters the body it is recognized by
IgE antibodies that are bound to mast
cells and basophils which sends a signal
to the mast cells to release the
preformed mediators which include
chemicals like histamine serotonin
heparin protease is like tryptase and
kinase ATP and lysosomal enzymes however
the most important of them is histamine
histamine acts on blood vessels and
leads to their dilation which leads to
delivery of more inflammatory cells and
chemicals to the site of allergy
histamine also causes increased
permeability of blood vessels which
leads to increased transportation of
cells from blood vessels into the tissue
spaces this leads to local edema
erythema which means the redness of the
allergy site and raised local
temperature of the allergy site
histamine also depolarizes nerve endings
which leads to itching and pain now a
classical example of this is a mosquito
bite the bump and redness which develop
in seconds are nothing but the immediate
phase of type 1 reaction the late
reaction phase develops ours
after the initial exposure to the
allergen and involves synthesis of new
chemical mediators in the marcelles the
membranes of the mast cells have
phospholipids in type 1 reaction and
enzyme known as phospholipase is
activated this enzyme converts
phospholipids in the membrane to
arachidonic acid this is the parent
compound from which numerous
prostaglandins and leukotrienes are
synthesized now this topic deserves a
video on its own but in short these
newly synthesized chemicals lead to
infiltration of more inflammatory cells
at the site of allergy they lead to
tissue damage smooth muscle spasm and
edema that can last for days like the
Leo Train c4 d4 and e4 and the
prostaglandin d2
all these lead to vasodilation and
increased vascular permeability which
leads to continuous influx of
inflammatory cells at the site of
allergy they also cause smooth muscle
spasm you could try and be four leads
through infiltration of more cells like
neutrophils eosinophils because it is a
chemo attractant that means it is a
chemical which attracts other cells at
the site which it is produced
interleukin 5 is another important
cytokine that is produced by mast cells
and it is the most potent activator of
eosinophils these recruited cells
amplify and sustain the inflammatory
response without additional exposure to
allergen
the late phase reaction is the major
cause of symptoms in conditions like
asthma
so to summarize the type on
is a disorder of immune system that can
lead to many important medical
conditions like asthma angioedema
anaphylaxis food allergies etc it
involves two important phases a phase of
sensitization in which the allergen
enters the body for the first time and
our immune system forms a memory of this
illusion the phase of reaction begins
when the allergen enters the body again
it is quickly recognized by the IgE
antibodies bound to mast cells which
signals these cells to release huge
amounts of chemicals like histamine
serotonin prostaglandins which leads to
symptoms like itching pain redness
swelling and smooth muscle spasms so
this was all about the type 1
hypersensitivity reaction thank you so
much for watching guys in the next video
we are going to talk about the type 2
hypersensitivity reaction you can get
all the flashcards from this video and
all our other previous videos by joining
the meth simplified community on
patreon.com plus you will also unlock
many other cool features like written
content from videos behind the scenes
exclusive posts and much more visit
patreon.com slash meth simplified for
more